© transcript Emily Beynon
Bring him in here!
Miss Gaskell, get that fire lit, quick.
Miss Jones, bring in whatever blankets we have.
Mr. Pearson, see what we've got in terms of food.
Davy's dead.
There was nothing more you could have done.
What are we gonna do? We need supplies.
Well, first of all, you're gonna stay here, and you are gonna get yourself worn.
Now, I sent John and Mike a scout now to head.
Arthur and I, we're gonna ride out, see if we can find one of them.
And this, just for a short bit.
And I don't see what other choice we have.
Listen.
Listen to me, all of you, for a moment.
Now, we've had, well, a bad couple of days.
I loved Davy.
I loved you.
Jenny.
Sean, Mac, they may be okay.
We don't know.
But we lost some folks.
Now, if I could throw myself in the ground in their stead, I'd do it.
Gladly.
But we're gonna ride out, and we're gonna find some food.
Everybody.
We're safe now.
There ain't nobody following us through a storm like this one.
And by the time they get here, well, we're gonna be, we're gonna be long gone.
We've been through worse than this before.
Mr. Pearson.
Miss Grimshaw.
I need you to turn this place into a camp.
We may be here for a few days.
Now, all of you.
All of you.
Get yourselves warm.
Stay strong.
Stay with me.
We ain't done yet.
Come on, Arthur.
All right.
We've got some work to do.
Well, we ain't run into them yet.
So, they both must have headed down the hill.
Sure.
Well, hey.
I ain't had time to ask.
What really went down back there on that boat?
We missed you.
That's what happened.
Come on.
Oh.
Hey.
You need horses?
Oh, yeah.
Hey, Mr. Smith.
Get yourself indoors.
You need to rest that hand.
I'll live.
Get indoors, son.
Bye.
We need you strong.
Okay.
Bye.
And I need you to get me an về.
You guys probably...
a´ot councilor Mortensen
Or something.
to stick to the trail.